Khloe Kardashian helpless after Lamar  Odom was spotted at a bar over the  weekend possibly drinking the estranged  couple seemed fine on Sunday spending  the Easter holiday together a source  close to the reality star even tells ET  quote as of Monday Khloe and Lamar were  doing great but then early Tuesday  morning Khloe tweeted this I hate this  feeling helpless our source says that  Khloe is quote shocked that Lamar was  caught at a bar one thing is so clear  Khloe would it never get back with Lamar  unless she knew one hundred percent that  he was maintaining his sobriety so Hema  possibly drinking again is a huge slap  in her face eg source continues he  almost died if that's not enough to keep  him sober than what is if Lamar makes  this a habit Khloe will walk away for  good this time